Oh No one one thing once otherwise did
the divisive nature of this group you
talked about one of your main concerns
working with the community of a
grassroots level up you very well-known
in South London for doing that is that
this actually calls family strain family
problems between even husband and wife
we've got reports that ever Khadija for
example would be responsible for
divorces and actually you could say
misplaced you could say you know meddle
with family business
yes it's just all these true rumors I've
got first-hand accounts from X marks
about individuals who I'm in touch with
now how they split him from his wife so
what can you tell us is this a case
study here if this is a case study but I
will refer to the one I've got
documentation from right I mean awaits a
student in Medina right and started
getting calls from his wife because she
was being approached from some of the
cult members sisters and saying that
your husband has taken a position to
about particular scholar right I can't
recall which is but one of the big
scholars and the husband and it was a
point of for all not masu big issue here
and basically those sisters were saying
that your husband is not seller fee and
they were being driven by their husband
to do this and he was writing and the
brother who was an arbitrator came to me
and said can I share this information
with you I didn't know what I could do
in that instance but he shaved and I
read the information and letters from
the brother of the communication and he
said I want to speak to our Khadija how
am I not selfie hey what are these
individuals doing
then he wrote to another brother my
family I do not know where they are
Wow when he went back to the UK to
Birmingham they've been moved from their
home by the provision by the demotic a
lot they've been relocated yes from and
he said this is what they have done I
don't know where my wife is
Wow so this was something that was very
serious and I couldn't provide you with
the letters and everything it was
written in an English library by her
brother and as I've said I've been in
communication with other individuals who
have told me what happened with regards
to the occult being involved in
splitting
wife from from there what is the
incentive for this I mean what they do
that when they split their wives for
example is there if there a marital
incentive do you think that they try and
maybe get married to these women after
they've been divorced or and I can't say
what incentive is yes but then you do
see marriage afterwards to the most
orange member so wait so you're saying
there's a trend of after separation
between someone for example that they
disapprove off that they themselves
would put themselves forward for or
someone who's the proves buy them for
much yes well that says a lot to be
honest with you and is what else is
there in terms of incentive what is
driving these individuals to be like
that so divisive and solely in to and
their power and control power and
control yes I know students of knowledge
who have graduated from Wadena living in
Saudi Arabia and you can see that they
are mouthpieces for these individuals
and they are almost scared to interact
with other individuals who are known in
selfies because of what may happen as a
result they may send out general emails
of things they've translated and I might
speak to one or two of them and they
blind copy me and other individuals in
case those from the market ever seen
that they're including individuals who
they have issues with this is this
boiling you can only bully weak people
and the bully themselves a weak as you
know and this is a manner that they've
got when more robust individuals come
and confront or speak not just I'm not
talking just about violence in that
instance but when they know individuals
have a bit of testicular fortitude if
you like you will see them very cautious
in that balloon